okay rachel give us another question
this question is from bob key
hey bob
what advice would you give interns
starting out how can they make the most
of the opportunity in big companies
fantastic okay um we don't do
internships uh
uh anymore
really i mean we pay people to do
summer work or something like that so
it's kind of an internship but
i find the unpaid internship is like
just more trouble than it's worth in
america because you'll get sued
and we've seen tons of lawsuits for that
and
if somebody's there for eight ten weeks
they're just a drag on somebody who's
highly productive so then somebody in
the company gets stuck with managing the
interns
and
they leave by the time they learn the
skill they're out the door so interns
are just really a difficult thing for
companies to contend with
i think the way you should think about
it is as an intern
to make connections to work hard to
prove that you
can listen and collaborate
that you can communicate
that you do what you're going to say
you're going to do basically
it's a way for you
on a performative basis to show
that you are a great person to have as
an employee so what i would recommend is
you get in an hour early stay an hour
late
you ask people really great questions
you ask them for advice
you do extra work on the weekend so if
they say hey do you know how to do
copywriting you say no
but i'll do some research on that for
sure do you have any places you can
point me to or even better than that
because now you're putting the onus on
them is you just type into youtube how
to be a great copywriter you go on
amazon you buy books so prove you're a
go-getter prove you go above and beyond
so when if the boss says hey can you do
some copywriting for us or write a press
release you say and they say have you
done they say no i haven't but i can
look online for it if i had somebody who
did that
i'd be like oh this is the type of
person i want so you're trying to just
prove that you
are a go-getter that you're a
rugged individualist who can find
answers on their own
and that you do what you say you're
going to do in other words you're going
to build that credibility
you just want to show you're a model
employee so again shortlist
you're fiercely independent you're able
to learn new skills you're hard-working
you're
you get in early you stay late you ask
good questions you communicate crisply
you don't waste people's time
you don't say stupid stuff like i've
never done that before or i mean if they
asked you've ever done it before you
should answer honestly but this idea of
like nobody told me like i find like a
lot of the interns are kind of like
paralyzed they don't know how to work in
a work environment being a go-getter hey
i got that job done is there anything
else i can do to be helpful
show you can be maximum helpful
prove that you can be of maximum value
and
if you're not then what's the point of
you even being there it's hard to be
valuable to a company
and uh that's what you should be you
should jump on it like if you look at
producer rachel here she's doing the
meetups
proving that she can be valuable and
something i'm sure she's never done
before uh and that's like just a small
example but prove that you can be of
service and that you can learn
you can get it done gsd
good question
you